Hello.
We are living during a historic moment
that's marked by difficult challenges,
as we all know, on the East Coast,
so that the world is shaken
by the crisis caused by
the covid-19 pandemic,
which highlights yet
an even bigger challenge now kuraishi
social and social environmental crisis.
This requires us, all of us,
to face a choice.
The choice between what matters
and what doesn't change
the choice between continuing to ignore
the suffering of the poorest Yamal and
to abuse our common home, the planet,
or in or engaging at every level that
it has to transform the way we act.
Science tells us every day with more
precision that urgent action is needed
and I'm not dramatizing here,
this is what science says
if we are to keep the hope of avoiding
radical and catastrophic climate change.
And for this, we must act now that
this is a scientific fact
on our conscience tells us
that we cannot remain indifferent to
the suffering of those in need
and recognition, these sort of
growing economic inequalities
and social injustices. And that's
the economy itself cannot be limited
to production and distribution,
and it must also consider its impacts
on both the environment and on
the dignity of people.
But we could say that the economy
should be strictly a creative.
In itself and in its methods.
In the way it acts, creative creativity,
what I would like to invite you
to go on a journey together,
a journey of transformation and of
action made not so much of words,
but rather of concrete
and pressing actions.
I'm calling it a journey because
it requires a shift,
a change that came from this crisis. None
of us must come out to the same.
We cannot come out to the same from a
crisis we never come out of the same.
It will take time.
Effort and hard work to overcome it.
We will have to take it one step
at a time of the week,
persuade those in doubt.
Imagine new solutions and commit
to carry them out.
Our goal is clear to build an approach
within the next decade,
plus a world where we can meet the needs
of the present generations and.
Included, including everyone since her
compromise without compromising
the possibilities of future generations.
I would like to invite all people
of faith, Christian or not.
And all people of goodwill. I intend
to embark on this journey.
From your own faith, or if you do not have
a faith from your own intention,
from your own good, will each one of us
as individuals or members of a group,
families, communities of faith, businesses
, associations, institutions,
can make a substantial contribution.
Only five years ago, I wrote the
encyclical letter Lerato C,
dedicated to the care of our common home.
She proposes the concept of integral
ecology to respond,
to respond together to
the cry of the Earth,
as well as to the cry of the poor ecology.
Integrally integral ecology is an
invitation to an integral vision
on life aberrated, starting from the
conviction that everything in
the world is connected and that, as the
pandemic made sure to remind us,
we are interdependent on each other. And
that, as well as on our Mother Earth.
The television from such
a vision stems to
the need to find new ways
of defining progress
and measuring insincerely mythology
without limiting ourselves to
the economic, technological, financial
and gross product aspects not done,
but rather giving central relevance
to its ethical,
social and educational dimensions.
But I would like to propose today
three courses of action.
Got to see, as I wrote in Lerato see the
change and the right orientation
for our journey of integral ecology
required first that we all take
an educational step.
We. So my first suggestion is
to promote at every level
and education geared towards the care
of our common home and developing
the understanding that environmental
problems are linked to human needs.
You must understand this
from the beginning,
that you need to establish environmental
problems are tied to human needs
and education based on scientific
data and on an ethical approach.
This is important, both of
them being encouraged by
the fact that many young people
already show a new ecological
and social awareness and many of them
fight generously for the defense of
the environment and for justice.
As a second proposal today, we must
focus on water and nutrition.
Access to safe and drinkable water is an
essential and universal human right.
And embracing it is essential because
it determines the survival of people
and therefore is a condition for
the exercise of all the rights
and responsibilities as an element, as
providing adequate nutrition for all
through nondestructive farming methods
should become the main purpose of
the entire cycle of food production
and distribution.
That has proposed the third suggestion
is about energy transition.
Who knows how a gradual replacement,
but without delay of fossil fuels,
with clean energy sources?
We only have a few years essentiality,
Galchen scientists estimate approximately,
maybe less than 30. We have
a few years, less than 30,
30 years to drastically reduce greenhouse
gas emissions into the atmosphere.
Davis is not only must this transition be
quick and capable of meeting present
and future energy needs, he said it also
must be attentive to the impact on
the poor, on local populations,
as well as on those who work in
the energy production sectors.
One way to encourage this change
is to lead businesses towards
the urgent need to commit themselves to
the integral care of our common home
is excluding from investments those
companies that do not meet the parameters
of integral ecology
and equally, while rewarding those that
work concretely during this transitional
phase, change the law to
put sustainability,
social justice and the promotion
of the common good at
the center of their activities.
Well, they already said
many organizations,
Catholic and of other faiths,
have already taken on the responsibility
to act in this direction.
In fact, in fact, the earth
must be worked and nursed,
cultivated and protected.
We cannot continue to squeeze
it like an orange.
And we can say that this request taking
care of the Earth is a human right.
These three proposals must
be considered as part of
a larger group of actions that
we must carry out in
an integrated way in order to find a
lasting solution to these problems.
The current economic system
is unsustainable.
From there, we are faced with
the moral imperative and
the practical urgency to rethink
many things the way we produce,
the way we consume our culture of waste,
our short term vision,
the exploitation of the poor and
our indifference towards them.
The growing inequalities and our
dependence on harmful energy sources.
And we need to think about
all these challenges,
ecology and integral ecology suggests
a new conception of
the relationship between
us humans and nature.
We support this leads to
a new economy where
the production of wealth is directed
to the integral well-being of
the human being and to the improvement,
not the destruction of our coming home.
It also implies a renewed politics
conceived as one of
the highest forms of charity.
She yes.
Love is interpersonal, but
love is also political.
It involves all peoples and
it involves nature.
Need to be there for all of you
to embark on this journey.
That they proposed in order to. And
also my new encyclical fatality.
As the term countdown's suggests,
we must act with urgency.
So each one of us can play
a precious role.
So if we all begin our journey today,
not tomorrow, today,
because the future is built today.
And she goes to it and it is
not built in isolation,
but rather in community and
in harmony. Thank you.